moi je fais pas mal de mouvements
justement gilet jaune depuis le début je
fais pas mal les manifs et c'est pas du
tout j'ai pas du tout une porte ce truc
pourquoi je pense est une arnaque totale
que c'est juste pour enfumer les gens
encore une fois que voilà je pense que
c'est tout croyez pas toutes ces
remarques qui vont être remontés qu'est
ce que vous faites là juste de la com
qui essayait de faire de la com comme
d'habitude et puis derrière n'y aura
rien y faire à de petites annonces et
comme il avait fait pour ces 100 euros
de plus ce machin et puis bah ça aidera
la chance que lui c'est une façon
son objectif est que ça non moi je veux
plus enfin le système actuel de pour
voter etc
ça ne je voterai plus tant que ce sera
comme ça c'est clair et net
donc ce sera commence donc ce sera des
2e tour avec des chantres le pen et
macron ça aucun intérêt pour moi c'est
juste de la com en dire c'est juste de
la comédie quoi pendant des mois et on
faire une campagne machin faire genre
qui compromettent des tonnes de choses
faire semblant de s'intéresser aux gens
alors qu'ils n'ont rien à [__] et puis
voilà oui pour ça que je vais faire les
manifs le samedi et c'est parce que
justement je pense qu'on est justement
ça a montré qu'on était capable de tout
se mobiliser pour quelque chose
quelque chose de meilleur donc si moi
j'y crois je suis page pas défaitiste
juste que moi je fais un constat qu
actuellement c'est c'est pas bon quand
spam ou vendre